you say you can't have children but
there are other ways of choosing a
successor I can't have children who told
you that there weren't you were murdered
my husband has it occurred to you she
might not have been a reliable source of
information
hey everybody this is gonna be my new
season 8 Q&A just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened so far
there was someone that actually asked
about the night king becoming a dragon
rider in the need for Targaryen blood in
order to be able to dragon bond but just
to answer that first you actually don't
have to be a pure blood Targaryen
there's actually somebody mentioned
during the world of Ice and Fire book in
princess in the Queen the short story
from the dance of the Dragons the
historical Targaryen Civil War the
woman's name was nettles she was able to
win the dragon over by bringing it sheep
every day for about a month so it's just
an example of how a normal person was
able to bond with a dragon but the way
the Targaryens tell it they're the only
ones that are able to do it I think
partly to prevent other people from
developing aspirations you can see how
they used that to sort of control
Westeros the dragons were there controls
even if it were true that you did need
Targaryen blood in order to be able to
bond with dragons his magic is so
powerful that I think the idea is that
he raised the dragon from the dead in
any bond that he has with it now is just
a result of that here we go next
question the natascha asked do you think
that maester aemon knew about jon snow's
true lineage if so why didn't he say
anything well he did say that a
Targaryen alone in the world is a
terrible thing so he kind of did say
something but I don't think it
necessarily confirmed whether he knew
the really cool thing about maester
aemon though is that he was in
correspondence with Rhaegar before he
died they talked about prophecy they
talked about dragon lore so I don't
think that Maester Aemon knew 100% that
Jon Snow was Rhaegar son but I do think
that he had an idea for what Rhaegar was
trying to do so it's always possible
that he put two and two together when he
saw the events of Robert's rebellion
playing out in Rhaegar and Lyanna 'he's
untimely end so he probably had his
suspicions it just kept his mouth shut
to try and not cause any more problems
because that's the whole deal even if
the people at the wall would have found
out about it word would have gotten back
to the kingdom they would have ridden up
and either tried to execute him or start
another rebellion in his name next one
Siham asks why do you think that no one
mentioned Valyrian steel can kill the
White Walkers do you think the Jaime
John Brienne Sam and Arya all of them
have an important role in the great war
because of the Valyrian steel that they
have so yes I absolutely
think that they are special people
because of the swords that they wilt and
I think part of the reason why they
didn't mention Valyrian steel
specifically is to save that for Season
eight when you go back to re-watch these
episodes they spend all this time
talking about dragonglass
they took dragonglass weapons with them
during episode six you just don't see
the clear moment when they change from
their regular weapons to the dragonglass
weapons when they're standing on the
rock here but the thing is is that
Samwell in the books
refers to the sword as dragon's steel so
I don't think that they wanted to
confuse people and they just wanted to
say something extra special for season
eight next one toxic whisper asks do you
think that they'll use the actual ending
that Martin gave them you're talking
about Dan and Dave or will they try to
end the series on their own and then
your second question who in your opinion
will become more distant once John's
true heritage is revealed well to answer
your second question first I'll say John
will probably have the bigger problem
because he grew up being a bastard he
has all these parental issues Catelyn
never loved him but they'll probably
both pull away from each other I don't
think that one of them will try to
convince the other that they should go
forward with it I think it'll be a
mutual thing but to answer your first
question
Martin's original ending you know who
knows what that actually is but it
sounds like they got an inkling of it in
that hotel room a couple years ago like
where they learn ho doors name they
learned as much as they could but
therein lies the problem they said as
much as possible meaning that Martin
couldn't tell them every single little
thing because he hasn't written it yet
there's even been a lot of new stuff
that he said that he's added in two
winds of winter just in the last year so
this was a couple years ago when they
met so there was stuff that he hadn't
even thought of yet so that's also going
to happen with dream of spring so I
think when we say they're doing the
George are Martin ending on the TV show
I think it'll be the spirit of the
George R Martin ending but there'll be a
bunch of characters that are different
there'll be a lot of dialogue that isn't
the same because he may have given them
a couple lines like oh the series is
supposed to end with a couple lines of
dialogue that read like this next one
hey there dude asks do you think that
they'll focus on the whites coming and
wait on the incest drama for later in
the season no I think they'll try to
drop that bomb pretty early so that
it'll drive them apart while they have
to face the wise like before any big
major assaults happen but here's the
thing is that they'll probably wait till
after they've been together together for
a great long while like they will have
been on that boat they'll been a white
Harbor on their way to Winterfell so it
will ensure that it will be suitably
awkward and disgusting when they find
out next one Lenalee asked do you think
that there's any possibility that John
and Daenerys are the two heads of the
Dragon with the possible future child
being the third so you're talking about
their future child I think it's totally
possible but you know previously people
thought it was Tyrion now because
there's only two dragons and it's the
night king it's definitely not Tyrion so
the whole thing about the three heads of
the Dragon is that I think it's open to
interpretation so I don't think it's
specifically talking about any potential
future child I think that they'll have
some fun with the idea like the third
head of the Dragon should be called the
night king now that he's riding the
third dragon so if we actually get any
sort of payoff on the three heads of the
Dragon I think it'll be more
metaphorical and it'll work for a couple
of different storylines the way that
prophecies do like the whole idea that
Jon Snow is the child of Ice and Fire
but together Jon Snow and Daenerys are
also the Song of Ice and Fire but again
I don't think the show's gonna get super
literal with that there'll be a lot of
eye winking they always like to
reference prophecies like they did with
Melisandre when she came to meet
Daenerys prophecy is a tricky thing
the next question Joseph ass why would
Tyrion go after Arya he was married to
Sansa
so that's like marrying one sister but
actually wanting the other so I think
you're confused about the original
treatment for the books and what the TV
show ended up doing so during my last
video I talked a little bit about George
RR Martin's original outline when it was
going to be three books instead of the
seven that we have now there was going
to be a love triangle between Arya Jon
and Tyrion but that was way before he
wrote the first book so obviously that
changed a lot and then we got to the TV
show which changed the books again they
haven't explicitly stated there's any
kind of love triangle on the horizon but
again I think you're also confused on
the TV show when he got married to Sansa
it wasn't because he wanted her it was
because they were forced to get married
that's why he didn't consummate the
marriage because he felt like she was so
put upon he was trying to do the right
thing look I'm not gonna force you into
this so then later it was much easier to
annul their marriage because it was
never consummated next one Rob asks
could you speculate a bit on the gods in
the show
and what role they might play in season
aid I'm especially thinking of the Lord
of Light I still think that he's an evil
entity so I think the whole idea with
the Lord of Light is that he's impartial
or she's impartial however you want to
think about it is an impartial force
it's not good or evil right up until
they made the big night King revealed
that the children of the forest created
him there was all these different
thoughts about the different gods their
interpretations which God is the same
God or these just a bunch of different
beliefs based around the same
supernatural force so the old gods which
is who the children of the forest
worship are basically the earth they
worshiped the planet so that's where
their power comes from that's how they
created the night king so as far as we
know that is where the Lord of Light
resides now there's a lot of speculation
on whether or not we'll see a literal
supernatural force manifest or if it'll
just be the people on the show battling
each other like if we're gonna go
full-blown wizard battle is there an
actual consciousness to the Lord of
Light that's the real question and
Martin has been relatively ambiguous but
the really cool thing is that we do know
that magic exists because the faceless
men in the books use a measure of magic
when they're changing their faces but
hopefully it wins a winter we'll get
some more context and we'll get an idea
for just how many different gods there
are or if it really is just the One God
next one Alma asks do you think that
Arya will become kendrys lady
so yeah I'm sure there's gonna be all
kinds of Aria Gendry stuff happening in
season eight remember she said that's
not me so the only way that they wind up
together is if he runs off with her
there are a lot of people that want to
see him legitimized by John Snow and
Daenerys but if he were to take storms
in then she wouldn't want to be the lady
of a castle so I think it just depends
on how true you think that she's going
to stay to her character and whether or
not she's going to survive the final
season next one David asks do you have
any update on Jack and Hegar where is he
what about the theory that he's actually
Rhaegar Targaryen so I'll say right away
I do not think that he's Rhaegar
Targaryen but he might come back in the
final season just as a sort of i wink to
the fans in the books he's actually
inside the Citadel trying to get
information so he's a little more
critical to the plotline after he's been
training Arya so because the TV show has
changed his character so much I think
the most that we could expect from him
is for him to show up and see
what re is made with herself it who sort
of winked from behind the camera while
he goes off to pursue another mission
because he's still a faceless person so
he's going around the world executing
contracts he doesn't stop doing that
just because he's done with aria next
one but he asks I want to know who was
the liar about the Rhaegar Liana
marriage that started the rebellion so
you're asking if somebody lied when they
ran off together I actually don't think
that they knew that they ran off
together
way before Rhaegar and Lyanna ran off
together hoster Tully and Jon Arryn were
sort of plotting to overthrow the Mad
King so then what happened is is when
Liana ran off with Rhaegar they thought
that he kidnapped her so Brandon stark
and Rickard went to the Mad King to
petition him he ended up killing both of
them and then sort of the background
plot to overthrow the Mad King gained
some steam Robert and Johnny air and
mobilized forces in the first big battle
that actually happened during Robert's
rebellion was closer to the Vale so even
if Rhaegar and Lyanna hadn't ridden off
with each other there probably would
have still been a rebellion that would
just start much later in the timeline
next one fo asks what was the first time
John hears about Daenerys in the book so
I believe that was actually when he sent
maester aemon with Samwell to the city
at all and maester aemon is isn't his
death throes he's getting ready to die
and starts talking about Daenerys about
how he wants to go become her maester
she's not mentioned a whole lot while
they're up at the wall but there are
like some brief rumblings about it like
when he starts telling a Targaryen alone
in the world is a terrible thing there's
also sort of references to Daenerys in
that too so it's not like they have long
conversations about her you have to
remember that the last book ended with
the Nights Watch revolting against him
killing him and that's the end of it
wins a winter picks up right after that
so like right where season 6 begins
pretty much but thank you so much for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do my future q and A's will
probably be a little more specific based
on topic and what you guys want to talk
about the most so I will keep doing them
in addition to the bonus videos but I'll
say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Elektra one please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here for all my
season 8 videos and you can click here
to learn a little bit about Rhaegar and
Lyanna during the rebellion thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
tonight